[MUSIC PLAYING]
THOMAS BOTTRILL:
Oh hi, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
Today, I'm going to
be talking about how
you can run Microsoft SQL Server
in Compute Engine in a highly
available manner.
And by the end of
the session, I want
you to know what
that looks like,
the issues you might
run into, and where
you can go to get more
information on setting this up.
I won't be talking about
the Cloud SQL announcement
from yesterday.
But I do feel a little bit
blindsided by it, to be honest.
So first, I wanted to talk
about myself for a little bit.
My name is Tom.
I'm a reliability
engineer at Rackspace.
I've been at Rackspace
for about 5 and 1/2 years.
And I've been working with
Google Cloud for the past 18
months.
My background is
as a Windows SysAd,
which I did for over
10 years, and which
is why about 18 months ago, I
was asked to join and manage
a Google team as the first
Windows expert globally.
Now, my first task
in that role was
to figure out just how we
could support Windows in GCP.
And my second task
was to figure out how
we can do highly available SQL.
So a lot of what you're
going to see here
is based on my first
few months in that role,
as well as some learnings
that we've taken
from customers along the way.
So you may have
noticed the picture.
I have rather a
few flags in there.
And that's because
that Rackspace likes
rewarding rankers with flags.
Each of those represents
a different certification
that I managed to achieve.
And I actually have
all of the GCP certs,
including the Network
and Security ones.
I have a couple of
Microsoft certs as well.
So I think that makes
me pretty well-placed
to talk about the subject.
Finally, you may have
noticed my accent.
I'm not from around here.
I'm from a little
island called Britain
that you may have heard of.
There are a few things going
on there at the moment.
But thankfully, I get
to distract myself
by watching the rugby.
Although, please avoid any
talk about the Six Nations,
because that's still
a bit of a sore point.
If you don't know
what rugby is, it's
a bit like American
football, except there's
a lot less padding, and we
throw the ball backwards,
rather than forwards.
Now, you didn't come
here to listen to me
talk about myself all day.
So this is what I'm
going to be covering
for the rest of the session.
I'm going to start
off by looking
at the various options that
are available in SQL Server.
And that won't just be from a
high availability perspective.
I'm also going to cover
things like disaster recovery
and read scaling.
This will be quite general.
It won't be GCP-specific.
The GCP-specific stuff is
going to be in section 2,
where I'll show you what
a highly available SQL
architecture in GCP
actually looks like.
I'll also talk through
a few of the caveats,
a few of the things that
you need to watch out for.
And then I'll move on
to doing a quick demo
just so you can see what
it looks like in real life.
So let's start by
looking at what options
are available in SQL Server.
And you can see this
rather nice Venn diagram.
I have three main
areas on there.
There's High
Availability if you want
to be protecting against
individual instance failures.
There's Disaster
Recovery if you want
to be protecting against
entire region failures.
And there's also Read Scaling
if either your application has
quite high read
requirements or you
have a geographically-redundant
app, geographically spread
out, that would benefit
from more data locality.
So for high availability, one of
the options you might consider
is failover clustering.
It's a much older technology,
much more widely known.
And especially if you
already have existing SAN
infrastructure, it
might be a good option
for you, at least on-prem.
For disaster recovery,
you might have thought
about using SQL mirroring.
Although, Microsoft
are deprecating that in
favor of the basic
availability group,
which I'll be talking
about a bit later on.
Log shipping is
probably a better option
if you're just doing
disaster recovery.
It's a lot more
simple to set up.
It has very few requirements.
It's essentially just a few
SQL jobs that the run on nodes
to backup databases
on one instance
and restore them on another.
So it's very easy.
You can also do read scaling
if you really want to.
But I probably wouldn't
use log shipping for that.
If you're trying to do
transactional read scaling,
log shipping isn't
really a good fit,
because your clients are going
to be constantly disconnected
when those restore
operations are happening.
And there's also going to
be quite a bit of latency
between the backup
and the restore.
So for transactional
read scaling,
you're probably better off with
something like replication.
It's a bit more complex to
set up than log shipping,
but it is pretty good
at doing read scaling.
And then in the middle,
you have AlwaysOn.
AlwaysOn can actually do
all three of these things.
It can do high availability.
It can do disaster recovery.
And it can do read scaling.
So if you want one technology
that can do all three
of these things, AlwaysOn
is a really good option.
Before moving on,
I will point out
that you can actually mix
and match these as well.
So you could have
a failover cluster
that uses log shipping
for disaster recovery
if you wanted to.
For the rest of
the session though,
I'm just going to
focus on failover
clustering and AlwaysOn.
That's because they're the
high availability options.
So let's start by taking a
look at failover clustering.
As I said, it's a
much older technology,
quite well understood.
And it's a pretty
simple concept.
You have an IP
address up there that
can flow between all of the
instances in your cluster.
And that's what your client
will use to access the instance.
You have multiple servers
as members of your cluster.
And then to those
servers, you present
some kind of shared storage.
That shared storage is
typically a SAN LUN.
So you need some existing
SAN infrastructure there.
It can also be an
SMB 3 file share
if you're using Windows
Server 2016 or above.
But if you are
using a file share,
you need to make sure that's
highly available as well.
And then you put your
databases, both your databases
and the system databases,
on that shared storage.
This is what it looks
like in normal operation.
You have the IP address
on the active instance.
You have the SQL
Services running
on only the active instance.
They're stopped on all
of the passive instances.
You have that shared
storage mounted
on the primary instance.
And you have that primary
instance servicing the traffic.
When you initiate a
failover, the SQL Services
are first stopped on
the primary instance.
That process can actually take
a few seconds to complete,
because SQL will wait for
any pending transactions
to complete.
But once the services
have stopped,
the shared storage
will be dismounted
from the primary
active instance.
The IP address will be removed
from that instance's NIC.
The storage will be mounted
onto a passive server.
And then the IP
address will be added
to your passive server's NIC.
Finally, the services
will be started up
on the passive server.
Now, the amount of time it takes
for SQL Services to start up
can be quite variable.
It can also be quite
a long period of time.
When the SQL Services
start up, they
have to read some database and
table metadata into memory.
And certain transactions
may need to be replayed.
So you may find that this whole
process could take anything
from 30 seconds to
complete, if you
have relatively small
databases, up to a few minutes
if your database is
a terabyte in size.
And that's 30 seconds
to a few minutes
that your client's
aren't unable to access
any of these databases.
So failover itself
can be quite slow.
So if we go over a few of the
considerations for a failover
cluster, you only require a
single copy of the databases,
because they exist on
that much shared storage.
There is a requirement
for shared storage.
As I said, that will typically
be a SAN LUN or an SMB 3 file
share.
The failover can
be relatively slow,
just because of the process
it has to go through.
You can't span data
centers natively with this.
And what I mean by that is there
is nothing in the SQL failover
cluster that will allow
you to span data centers.
You can actually achieve this
if your SAN array supports
block-level replication, or
if you're using Windows Server
2016, where you have options for
using block-level replication
within that.
But with what you get
with a failover cluster,
this isn't something
you can actually do.
And most passive
servers are really
just sat there, doing nothing.
I kind of need to
caveat that slightly.
So the passive servers aren't
unable to service traffic
for an individual
failover cluster instance.
That is only active on
a single node at a time.
But you can actually add
multiple failover cluster
instances to the
same Windows cluster.
Although, bear in mind
if you do that, then
you need some kind of
logic in your application
to know which instance to
connect to for the database
you're trying to access.
So now let's move on to
AlwaysOn, specifically
availability groups.
This was introduced
in SQL Server 2012.
The standard availability
groups are currently
only available in the
Enterprise Edition of SQL.
Although in the
Standard Edition of SQL,
you can use the basic
availability group.
The basic availability
group is a lot
like a standard
availability group.
It just has a few
key limitations,
such as only being able to
have a maximum of two servers
as a member of that
availability group
and only being able to have a
single database within there
as well.
You also can't use read scaling
with the basic availability
group.
Before going into AlwaysOn
in a bit more detail,
first, I just want to
cover a couple of terms,
just so we all
know what they are.
An availability group is the
simplest unit of failover
within an AlwaysOn cluster.
You add your databases
to the availability group
and you failover an
entire availability group,
which means that all the
databases within there
will be failed over
at the same time.
You can only add a database
to a single availability
group at the time.
But a single SQL instance can
host multiple availability
groups at the same time.
An availability group may also
have zero or more listeners.
The listener is the access
point that the client will use.
It has a DNS name, which
is what the client should
use to connect.
And it also has one
or more dedicated IPs.
A listener can
only be associated
with a single availability
group at the time.
And through
Management Studio, you
can only assign
a single listener
to an availability group.
As I said, an availability group
can have multiple listeners.
But to do that, you have to go
into Failover Cluster Manager,
add the listeners there, and
then run some T-SQL whenever
you perform a failover.
If you go to the link on the
screen or scan the QR code,
it will take you to
some documentation that
shows you how to set those up.
You may be wondering why
you want multiple listeners,
and I'll talk about
that a bit later on.
This is what
AlwaysOn looks like.
You still have the
single listener
that can float between all of
the servers in the cluster.
You still have multiple
servers in the cluster.
But the key difference
here is that you
don't have any shared storage.
Each of these servers has
its own set of local storage.
On that local storage,
you add your databases
or you add your databases
to the availability group.
And then those databases
will be replicated
to the storage on all of the
instances within the cluster.
However, what isn't replicated
are any other system databases.
So when you install
a SQL instance
in an AlwaysOn cluster, what
you actually just installed
is a normal SQL instance.
The same way you would if
you weren't using AlwaysOn.
It does mean that you can
use GC Images to build these,
by the way, and then add
them to a cluster afterwards.
So because the system
database is unreplicated,
that means anything that
you add to a system database
needs to be added to all of
these instances individually.
So SQL log-ins, SQL jobs,
they don't get replicated.
You somehow have to
manage adding them
to all of these instances.
This is what AlwaysOn
looks like in service.
The listener is on
the active instance.
The services this
time are running
on all of the servers in the
cluster at the same time.
They're not stopped on
any of the passive ones.
And you have the primary
database in read/write mode.
You also have the secondary
database in read-only mode.
And then you have the primary
database replicating over
to the secondary database.
When you initiate a failover,
the primary database
is marked as read-only, the
direction of replication
is split, the secondary database
is marked as read write,
and the listener is moved
to the secondary instance.
And that's it.
That's a failover complete.
Now, you may think
that looks quite quick.
Actually, this is a
really quick process.
It probably will take you a
few seconds most of the time.
What's even better is that is
an actually predictable amount
of time.
There is a
configuration parameter
you can set in your
availability group
to say how long this failover
should take to complete.
Now, I did mention you can also
use an AlwaysOn availability
group for read scaling.
And this is how you would do it.
So for normal client request
to an availability group,
the client will connect
to the listener.
The listener will connect the
client to the active instance.
And then the active instance
will service the request.
If you want to use read-only--
if you want to use
read scaling, you
need to take advantage
of read-only routing.
To do that, you specify this
in your connection string,
ApplicationIntent=ReadOnly.
The client will still
connect to the listener.
The listener will still
connect the client
to the primary instance.
However, the difference here is
that the primary instance will
see that this has been specified
in the connection string,
and rather than servicing
the request itself,
it will consult its
read-only routing list
to determine which instance
should service the request.
Now, the read-only
routing list effectively
says that if this particular
instance is active,
then these instances are able
to service read requests for it.
So you could have a
read-only routing list
that says whenever
SQL 1 is active,
then both SQL 2 and SQL 3 are
able to service a request.
And you could have a
second entry in there
that says that if
SQL 2 is active,
then only SQL 1 is able
to service that request.
So once the active
instance has consulted
its read-only
routing list, it'll
pick an instance for the
client to connect to.
It will tell the client to
connect to that instance.
And then the client, or
the secondary instance,
will service the request.
So these are the
considerations that you
have for AlwaysOn generally.
Each node has to have a
copy of the databases on it,
so your storage
requirements might
be increased by using this.
However, there is no
requirement for shared storage,
so you can actually get away
with using cheaper storage.
The failover is relatively
fast and can actually
be predictable.
And you can natively span
data centers with this.
The underlying technology here
is essentially SQL mirroring.
And because of that,
your SQL instances
can actually be anywhere.
They could be on-prem.
They could be in
another cloud provider.
another GCP region.
It doesn't really matter.
You can put them anywhere.
And finally, those secondary
instances can get some use.
They can be used
as read replicas.
So what would I recommend
you actually use in GCP?
And this has kind of
changed slightly given
the announcement yesterday.
So I'd say if what you're
looking for is highly available
SQL and you have very
standard requirements,
then actually the
managed Cloud SQL
offering might be a pretty
compelling offer, because it's
a PaaS option.
You won't have so much
management overhead.
The only problem is you won't
get as much flexibility.
So if you wanted to
do high availability
and still maintain the
flexibility of managing
your own SQL
instances, you really
have the choice between failover
clustering and AlwaysOn.
The problem with
failover clustering
is this requirement
for shared storage.
In GCP, a persistent
disk can only
be mounted to a single instance
at a time in read/write mode.
That means that you can't
really use shared storage in GCP
for a failover cluster.
You could create-- you could
use the block level replication
options within Windows Server
2016 to get around that.
But then you're adding
additional management overhead
and additional
complexity to this.
And really, you
might as well just
use AlwaysOn from the
start, because it's designed
for this type of scenario.
The one thing you
may be considering
there is the licensing
cost, because as I said,
for a standard
availability group,
you have to use the
Enterprise Edition of SQL.
That means you're paying a
much larger licensing cost.
However, you may
be able to get away
with using the basic
availability group.
You may find that the
limitations don't really
affect you that much.
So now, let's take a look
at what AlwaysOn actually
looks like within GCP.
So what I'm going
to build up here
is a diagram that shows
you a single region
deployment of AlwaysOn.
After building that
diagram up, I'll
explain what slight
differences there
would be with a
multi-region deployment.
So you'll start by
picking a region.
That region should have
at least three zones.
And then you'll pick three
of those zones to use.
I've called them zone
A, zone B, and zone C.
You'll then create
three subnets.
One of those subnets will be
your shared services subnet.
That will have instances
deployed into it in all three
of these zones.
You'll then have a
second subnet, which
I've called the SQL 1 subnet.
That will have a single
instance deployed into it.
And that instance
will be in zone A.
And then you'll create
your third subnet.
That again will have a single
instance deployed into it.
And that instance
will be in zone C.
You'll then create two domain
controllers, both in subnet 1,
with one of them in zone A
and one of them in zone C.
The reason we create them
in those zones is to avoid--
is to minimize the intrazone
traffic between the SQL
instances and the
domain controllers.
Although, again, given Google
announced managed AD yesterday,
that might be a good
option to use as well.
You'll also create
a file share witness
in zone B. The file share
witness is effectively
just a file server.
And all it's doing is
providing core room
for the cluster to avoid any
sort of split brain scenarios.
The reason we're
deploying it into zone B
is because a mark
of best practice
is to keep your file share
witness in a zone that doesn't
have any SQL services in it.
That's to avoid any sort of
network partitioning effects.
Once you've done that, you'll
create two SQL instances.
One of those SQL instances
will be in subnet 2.
The other one will
be in subnet 3.
Those SQL instances
will have their own set
of persistent disks.
They will also have an alias
IP range specified on them.
Now, if you don't know
what an alias IP range is,
it's effectively a
subnet of the subnet
that the instance
is deployed in.
And it tells GCP
that any requests
for IPs within
the alias IP range
should be sent to that instant.
So it just means you can
add additional IP addresses
to that instance.
And GCP will know how
to route the requests.
You'll then create
a Windows Cluster.
That Windows Cluster will
have the two SQL instances
as members.
It will also have the file
share witness as its core.
And it will have some core
cluster resources in there
as well.
Those cluster resources
will have a DNS name.
And they will also have two
IP addresses in this case.
That's because those
core cluster resources
will have an IP
address from each
of the alias IP ranges that's
specified on the SQL instance.
What this means is that
that resource can be hosted
on either of these instances.
Failover Cluster
Manager will check
to see if there is an IP
that is in the same subnet
as the primary IP of the
instance you're failing over
to.
And if there is, it will
bring that resource online.
You'll then create some
availability groups.
In this case, I've created two.
Those availability
groups will have
some databases within them.
Those availability
groups can also
be failed over independently.
And the availability groups
will have their own listeners.
Again, the listeners
will have a DNS name.
And they will have two IPs,
one from each of the alias IP
ranges on the SQL instances.
So that's the single region
deployment of AlwaysOn.
With the multi-region
deployment,
it looks quite similar.
There are only a
couple of changes
that you'd actually make.
The first is you would deploy
some domain controllers
into that region as well,
then create a shared services
subnet within that region.
You'd create at least two domain
controllers for redundancy.
You'll also create additional
SQL instances in that region.
And with those SQL instances,
you will create them
each in their own subnet, and
you will specify an alias IP
range on them.
You'll then add additional IPs
to all of the cluster resources
from those alias IP
ranges you specified.
Effectively, your
cluster resources
should have the same
number of IP addresses
as you have SQL instances
within that cluster.
Finally, the file share
witness should actually
be moved to its own
region, because if you
have a multi-region deployment,
the best practice there
is to ensure it's deployed
into a region that doesn't have
any SQL services within it.
Again, that's to avoid any
sort of network partitioning
effects.
So one of the
things you're going
to have to choose when you
create the availability group
is the availability mode.
You've got two choices here;
synchronous and asynchronous.
With the synchronous
availability mode,
transactions are only committed
on the primary database
once the secondary
databases have
confirmed that the transactions
have been committed on them.
This is really good from a
data consistency perspective,
because it means
you can guarantee
that the secondaries are up
to date with the primary.
However, from a write
performance perspective,
it's not quite so good.
Because your primary is having
to wait for your secondaries
to commit transactions,
you'll actually
find that your write
performance is decreased.
So you should only
really use this
when the latency between the
instances is relatively low
and data consistency is
your primary concern.
Asynchronous availability
mode, on the other hand,
commits the
transactions immediately
on the primary database, and
then the primary database
doesn't really care what
happens with the secondaries.
It's really good from a write
performance perspective,
because there is no impact
on your write performance.
However, it's not quite so
good from a data consistency
perspective, because
if you try to failover
to one of these
instances, there's
a chance you might lose data.
Now, the good news is
this isn't a choice
that you have to make at the
availability group level.
You can configure this
on each of the instances
within the availability group.
So the way that I would
typically see this being used
is that you would have
your primary region.
And the instances that you
deploy into your primary region
will use the synchronous
availability mode.
The reason for this is that the
latency between those instances
is going to be relatively low,
tens of milliseconds maybe.
And you're most likely to be
failing over between instances
within the same region.
If you deploy SQL instances
to any other regions,
you'll use the asynchronous
availability mode.
The reason for
that is that you're
unlikely to be failing
over to that region
unless there's a disaster.
And if there's a
disaster, you can probably
afford some data loss.
And the latency between the
instances in different regions
is relatively high.
You're looking at
hundreds of milliseconds
as opposed to tens.
So if you were to try and
use synchronous availability
across regions,
you'll probably find
that your write performance
is affected a bit too much.
So connectivity
is the next thing
you might be thinking
about, especially
because these listeners
might have multiple IPs.
So how exactly the clients
connect to those instances.
Well, as I said,
the clients should
connect using the DNS name.
And then the default
configuration,
the Failover Cluster Manager
will register every possible IP
address within DNS.
If you have an
AlwaysOn-aware client,
you should use this in
your connection string,
MultiSubnetFailover=True.
That will tell the
client to attempt
to connect to all of those IP
addresses at the same time.
And as soon as one of the
connections is successful,
it will stop trying to
connect to the rest of them.
This allows failover to
be as fast as possible.
Legacy clients,
unfortunately, are
going to get back a
list of IP addresses.
They're going to pick one
at random to connect to.
And if that happens to be an
IP address that isn't currently
online, your client's
going to get a timeout.
So if you do have
a legacy client,
you should configure these
two parameters on the listener
cluster resource.
The first is
RegisterAllProvidersIP,
which you should set to 0.
That tells the client
that it should only
register the currently
active IP address in DNS.
You should also lower
the HostRecordTTL.
By default, that's
set to 20 minutes.
And I don't know
about you, but I
don't want to be waiting
20 minutes for my client
to failover.
You should probably
reduce that to something
a lot more sensible.
Maybe start at 2
minutes, and see
if that's all right for you.
If not, lower it a bit more.
Although, do bear in mind,
the lower the HostRecordTTL,
the more DNS traffic is going
to hit your domain controllers.
If you do you want to be able
to configure these listener
parameters, you can go to
the link on the screen,
and it will take you
to get Github Gist that
will give you a PowerShell
snippet that shows you
how to do that.
What about Linux?
We're at a Google conference.
We should talk about
Linux at some point.
So the good news is
that you can actually
run SQL Server on Linux.
And you've been able to
since SQL Server 2016.
If you really wanted
to, you could run it
in a Docker container as well.
Also, since SQL Server 2016,
and in fact Windows Server 2016,
domain-independent availability
groups have been a possibility.
So in Windows Server
2016, Microsoft
introduced the
domain-independent cluster.
Previously, all the
members of a cluster
had to be part of
the same domain,
but in Windows Server 2016
that limitation was removed.
And members of a
cluster could be
from different domains,
different forests, or even just
were group joined.
The domain-independent
availability group
was introduced in
SQL Server 2016 just
as a way of creating
availability groups on top
of those domain-independent
clusters.
Now, this was brought along
to SQL Server on Linux
in SQL Server 2017.
And you're actually able to
create availability groups
on top of Pacemaker clusters.
You may also be wondering if
you can mix Windows and Linux
servers within the same
availability group.
And the answer is
that you sort of can.
The issue with it is
that you don't get
any sort of high availability.
And that's just because there's
no common Cluster Manager
to mediate the failover
of the IP address.
If you go through a
link on the screen,
there's a lot more
detail about how
you would set this up on Linux.
Now, you may be
wondering about backups.
It's quite an important topic.
And it's not really
one that I'm going
to get into a huge
amount of detail today,
mainly because it's probably
a session in its own right.
I will give you a
couple of options
that you could look, though.
The first is creating some SQL
jobs on each of the instances
within your cluster, putting
some logic in that job
to ensure it only runs on a
single instance at a time,
potentially just by seeing if
that instance is the currently
active one for the
availability group,
and then having it
set within a SQL job
to offload that backup
onto cloud storage.
There are also a number
of third party products
that you can use that will be
able to back up these databases
to cloud storage.
So I've gone about half an hour.
And I'm a reliability engineer.
And this is the first time
I've talked about monitoring.
Again, I'm not going to
go into lots of detail
about monitoring, mainly
because this is probably
an entire conference
in its own right.
However, I will say that the
Stackdriver Monitoring agent
can be installed on Windows.
And when it is
installed on Windows,
it's able to gather
SQL Server metrics.
The Stackdriver
Logging agent can also
be installed on Windows.
And by default, that
will collect only
the Windows event logs.
SQL Server does log some
things to the event log.
So you may be able to just
get away with logging those.
But you can also configure
Stackdriver Logging
to ingest text-based logs,
which SQL Server also keeps.
So Stackdriver Logging
would be a good option
for any sort of log management.
Finally, if endpoint health is
something you want to monitor,
Stackdriver monitoring
does actually
give you the option of
using uptime checks.
So you could see if that
would suit your purpose.
So finally for this
section, let's just
go over some considerations
for AlwaysOn in GCP.
Each SQL Server
Compute Engine instance
requires its own subnet.
The file share witness should
be in a zone in a single region
deployment or a region in a
multi-region deployment that
has no SQL instances in it.
Active Directory isn't
actually a requirement anymore,
but I still highly recommend
that you include it.
Mainly because it makes
management a lot easier.
And if you've ever tried setting
up certificate authentication
for SQL Server,
you'll probably wish
you had Active Directory
to use instead.
Synchronous replication
should be used for instances
that are in the same region.
And conversely,
asynchronous replication
should be used for instances
that are in different regions.
So now let's move
on to a quick demo
just so you can see
what this looks like.
A quick demo.
There we go.
So this is a GCP console.
You can see that there are
a number of instances here.
I have two domain controllers,
a file share witness,
and two SQL instances.
All of these instances
are in the same network,
and you can see that the two
domain controllers and the file
share witness are all
in the same subnet.
The two SQL instances
are in different subnets,
as you can see here.
If I take a look
at SQL 1, you can
see that it has an alias
IP range configured.
And that alias IP range falls
within the range of the subnet
that this instance is in.
If I switch over to SQL
1 and reconnect to SQL 1,
this is what Failover Cluster
Manager would look like.
You can see that the core
cluster resources are currently
running on SQL 1.
And if I scroll
down, you can see
that there is a resource
for the file share witness,
as well as a resource for the
DNS name for the core cluster
resources.
And if I expand
that, you can see
that the IP address
that's online
is the one from the
same subnet as SQL 1.
If I switch the roles that are
running within this cluster,
I have two availability groups.
ag1 is currently
running on SQL 1,
and ag2 is currently
running on SQL 2.
If I look at the
resources within ag1,
you can see that there is a
resource for the availability
group.
There's also a resource
for the listener.
And if I expand
the listener, you
can see that the IP
address that's online
is in the same subnet as SQL 1.
If I look at the
same thing for ag2,
you'll see the same resources.
The only difference here is that
the IP address that's online
is in SQL 2's subnet.
So if I switch over
to Management Studio,
you can see that SQL 1
has four databases on it.
All four databases are in
the synchronized state.
And SQL 2 has the same
four databases, again,
all in the synchronized state.
If I take a look at the
availability groups on SQL 1,
you'll see that SQL 1 is primary
for ag1 and secondary for ag2.
If I take a look
at SQL 2, you'll
see it's the other way around.
So let's take a look at
the properties of one
of these availability groups.
You can see that ag1 has two
databases in it; db1 and db2.
It also has two instances as
a member of the availability
group.
Those instances are both
using the synchronous commit
availability mode.
And I can actually easily
change this to asynchronous
if I want to just by
selecting it here.
They're also set to use the
automatic failover mode.
That just means that if one
of these instances fails,
the other can automatically
pick up from it.
I can change that to
manual if I would like to.
And in fact, if I'm using
the asynchronous commit mode,
then manual is my only option.
You can also see that
the instances are
set to be readable secondaries.
If I take a look at the
read-only routing list,
you can see that there
are two instances.
They each have their
own read-only routing
URL, which tells the
client where to connect to.
And then they have their
own individual read-only
routing list.
So now, let's try doing a
failover and see what happens.
So I actually have
an app running here.
It's very simple.
All it's doing is
every 5 seconds,
it's connecting to
each of the listeners,
running the SELECT
@@SERVERNAME SQL statement,
and just returning the
value of that command.
So that would tell us which
instance is currently active.
It also would give us a count
of the errors that are found
when attempting the connection.
So if we initiate failover
of ag1, all I need to do
is step through the wizard.
Select which instance
to failover to.
You can see in this
case there's going
to be no data lost, because I'm
using synchronous commit mode.
Connect to the instance
I'm going to failover to.
And then wait a few seconds
for the failover to complete.
There you go.
The failover is complete.
You can see that SQL 1
is now secondary for ag1.
SQL 2 is primary for ag1.
And if I go to Failover
Cluster Manager,
you can see that the
owner node is now SQL 2.
And the IP address that's online
is the one in SQL 2's subnet.
If I go to the app, you can see
that the active instance is now
SQL 2.
And there was actually an
error during that failover.
Let's try the same
thing with ag2.
So again, we initiate
the failover and step
through the wizard.
Wait a few seconds for
the wizard to complete.
And there we go.
ag2 is failed over.
Again, ag2 is now
primary on SQL 1.
And if we refresh SQL 2,
we'll see that ag2 is now
secondary on there.
Again, we go to Failover
Cluster Manager.
Check ag2.
The owner node is SQL 1.
And the IP address that's
online is in SQL 1's subnet.
If we go back over
to the app, you
can see that SQL 1 is now
the active instance for ag2.
And there were no errors
during that failover.
Now, it's worth
pointing out here
that actually it's normal to
get a connection failure when
the failover is completed.
And that's usually during
the point at which the IP
address is moved to one instance
to another, or in this case,
the IP address changes.
What you should
do in your app is
to have some kind
of logic in there
to reattempt the connection.
And you'll probably find
that on the second attempt,
it will probably be successful.
So use something like an
exponential backoff for it.
So that's it for the demo.
If we go back to the
slides, I did have a video
here just in case the demo
gods didn't smile on me.
But thankfully, that worked.
So I can skip over that.
If you go to the
link on the screen,
you will find some
step-by-step instructions
for how to set this up in GCP.
There will be some
G Cloud commands.
PowerShell snippets.
And it should hopefully give you
enough information to get this
up and running yourself.
I'll let you all take a picture.
And all that's
left for me to say
is thank you for coming along.
I hope you've found this useful.
I hope you've got some
useful information from here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]